u.s president joe biden squeezing
russia's economy even tighter now
banning imports of big ticket russian
products like caviar and diamonds and
stopping exports of u.s luxury goods
high-end cars and watches desired by
president vladimir putin's billionaire
backers they support putin they steal
from the russian people deutsche bank
has now joined hundreds of companies
across the globe pulling its business
out of russia
but putin continues to brush off the
impact of sanctions as he ramps up
deadly attacks in ukraine i think the
main idea is to kill ukrainians as much
as they can the biden administration is
under growing pressure from 40
republican senators to change course and
get poland's mig fighter jets into
ukraine even if that means through a u.s
military base we've gone from
incompetent by the biden administration
to this move is dishonorable president
biden still has more economic weapons he
could launch at russia including
directly sanctioning its stock market
and the country's largest state-owned
banks
but actions have ripple effects
including skyrocketing gas prices in the
u.s after america stopped buying russian
oil can you give me a loan it was over
50 dollars airline ticket prices are
rapidly rising too as the cost of jet
fuel surges
and the u.s is facing another crisis
from the war dozens of ukrainian
refugees flying to mexico to try and get
into america i don't have any other
place to go i have family and friends in
usa and they're ready to support me but
the u.s border is still officially
closed to asylum seekers due to covet 19
restrictions after multiple attempts a
few ukrainians are getting through to
have their cases heard right now we have
a trickle that's turning into a stream
that's going to turn into a flood the
u.n says more than 2.5 million
ukrainians have fled their country since
the war began next week the president
will sign a spending bill giving ukraine
nearly 14 billion dollars in military
and humanitarian aid but many lawmakers
and americans watching ukraine crumble
under russia's attacks say it's not
enough jennifer johnson global news
washington